hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm very
depressed so today we're checking out
the second official trailer for pan
starring Hugh Jackman and Rooney Mara I
saw the first trailer for this it looks
okay alright so this will be a fresh
reaction from brand even one two three
I love you my feet
you are extraordinary more than you can
imagine
I promise that you will see me again in
this world
or another
I'd be [ __ ] terrified
are you brave Peter try to be
names James Hook I'm trying to save your
life cat what let me handle this good
fair lady we come in peace our tribes
bravest warrior it was written when you
return to it unite against the pirate
if Blackbeard is going to destroy
everything I'll stand against it they're
near I will never back
whoa that's kind of scary game the of an
ancient prophecy tells of a boy
would be disappeared from this world
until he was old enough to return
in an uprising against me
because
make them believe
I believed ugly
you can say that again that looks quite
magical it does look bad it does look
very magical oh why didn't you like the
first one I don't remember why I wasn't
a big fan of the first trailer but that
one really got me excited I got my
nipple chills going on right now because
of that really yeah hopefully it's the
mermaids
no no it's Karen I felt that presence of
a little boy who was like that's why I
got nipple chills because of a little
boy no I can't say that I felt that
presence of like a little boy just
looking at all this wonderful mystery
magical stuff you know I've seen a lot
of movies that are about like a fish
outta water tail and they go to some
special place and especially the Peter
Pan story has been done several times
but not the origin of Penn yeah this is
a direct orange in a pan and then you
even get the origin a hook Garrett
Hedlund looks great his hook I love how
much fun he's having with the roll I
like the accent he's doing - what kind
of accent it's kind of really random
though I'm not sure what accent it is
but it sounds like he's normal speaking
voice sounds like an well he kind of has
a more of it all I've seen him in this
Tron Legacy so I don't really know what
he sounds like the I thought he's like
Australian or something he sounds like a
standard American that's it like a
standard American accent yeah but
there's a lot of like energy and
enthusiasm to the performance you know
like all of them though it's kind of the
same way it's a little bit of a little
bit fantastic a little bit over the top
but it still looks entertaining Oh like
the Penn franchise yeah Hugh Jackman his
black beard looks like a total he looks
like every actor looks like they're
having a lot of fun with this and of all
the actors I'm surprised to seeing this
it's actually Rooney Mara yeah I'm in
agreement with you because Rooney Mara
tends to take on more serious type of
work and if she takes on something
that's kind of like that or cheesy SH
like she has no problem admitting that
she wasn't a big fan of that like she
was in the Nightmare on Elm Street
reboot and she was even like yeah I was
a crappy film but I did it anyway it is
so nice here in something I know she's
for the most part pretty selective about
what she does doesn't mean everything
she does is good but if she's gonna take
on like a like a fantasy film and she's
a part of it as such a lead role like it
gives me a little bit more faith like
the actors look great but no it just
feels like a really fantastical time
yeah I mean Hugh Jackman does really
good films all the time too I think
yeah Hugh Jackman is fantastic as far as
like this film goes like it really looks
like a film of like wonder and mystery
like how many times have we seen a Peter
Pan story yet this feels fresh true it's
kind of like when finding a Finding
Neverland came by and it just put a
fresh take on it yeah but this is more
fantastical of course than that no
seeing a cool origin tale but also
getting to see like I'm really hoping
they'll capitalize more off of the
relationship with pan and hook yeah
that's what I was gonna say too because
you see them develop that friendship and
then to see where it goes
yeah that's what I'm mainly interested
in seeing is their portrayal of that you
know like it's been a while since we've
got into film where you're like wow this
is kind of magical and beautiful and I I
do get that vibe from the trailer alone
what I really liked as far as imagery
goes was the fish and the water bubbles
oh yeah and everything looks great it
kind of looks like it kind of seems a
little scary at times to me to when the
crocodile went jumping that's bad
anything with giant crocodiles freaks me
out
really yeah I learned about this movie a
Lake Placid yeah that's a horrible phone
but it's just gonna [ __ ] out of me
anyway rating time I will definitely be
catching pan in the theaters
I will probably see it in theaters all
right no screenshot for you that was
really bland anyway guys thanks for
tuning in if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the Rio rejects you
can check out the prices right channel
over here Randy price beatnik baseline
right baseline being a my bad I'm sorry
there's a lot of trailer reactions on
there too you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where if we get
enough followers product placement
usually I follow this up with some type
of sex trip using a prop around me but
understand let's do a shout out joy s a
car Doge ingress that sounds like a
racist word yeah I got a grass that
sounds like some type of check out my
youtube channel I just posted a new
video on how to make a peanut butter
banana dragon
let's enjoy we can't find your [ __ ]
video okay I typed in Derrick King grass
someone else came up there is nothing
about a peanut butter banana dragon so
you gotta fix your account because I
cannot find this thing about a peanut
butter dragon banana dragon banana
dragon I wants me to peanut butter
banana dragon that it went horrible it
destroyed everyone I've ever loved
alright I just destroyed itself because
ate it it's like self destructible
peanut butter banana dragon and his
mouth Brandi we're supposed I don't know
the rules of improv go yes and not or
I'm gonna change it no we had a great
bit of a peanut butter banana dragon for
Derrick ingress and now it's ruined you
weren't I was looking for the oak I was
looking for opening well it's kind of
hard to come up with a bit about a
peanut butter banana dragon yeah it's
hard I was ready to say yes and yeah I
had nothing
you tried